hallo liebe leute liebe zuschauer von
easyjet
wir sind ferrari und janosch hinter der
kamera wir sind das team von easy
thermen und wir haben heute neue pläne
die wir mit euch teilen möchten wie ihr
wisst besuchen wir gerne euch unsere
zuschauer und so waren wir in den
letzten wochen schon in in polen in der
slowakei in österreich und für diesen
herbst haben wir ganz große flächen wir
möchten nämlich zusammen
zum allerersten mal in die usa reisen
und euch dort besuchen
für unsere reise benötigen wir eure
unterstützung denn wir haben zwar unsere
flüge einfach schon gebucht aber
ansonsten noch gar nichts geplant und
jetzt kommt nämlich hier
wir können uns dabei helfen durch die
usa zu fahren und euch zu besuchen
ob ihr eine schulklasse seit oder leute
die zu hause privat lernen wir freuen
uns auf eure e mails auf eure videos und
wir hoffen dass möglichst viele von euch
uns einladen ein paar leute kennen
geschrieben besuchen werden aber
ansonsten sind wir komplett frei easy wo
kommen wir an
er kam in new york an von wolf linke
zurück
richtig und dazwischen haben vier wochen
zeit und wir können überall hinfahren
probier das möchte deswegen hoffen wir
dass möglichst viele von euch sich
melden und uns einladen denn wir möchten
mit euch gerne videos drehen und
natürlich auch deutsch lernen
neben euren ideen wo wir hinfahren
können benötigen wir auch unterstützen
damit wir überhaupt so weit kommen wenn
wir bisher nur die flüge bewusst aber
natürlich ist eine reise auch ein
bisschen teurer und wir hoffen dass er
uns dabei unterstützt und ihr könnt bei
uns in dieser kampagne wie meilen
sponsern
und hier gibt es fünf gründe warum er
uns unbedingt unterstützen sollte
mit einer kleinen einmalige spende könnt
ihr uns etwas zurückgeben über das wir
uns sehr freuen
wir gehen jede woche für euch raus und
drehen für euch diese sie dämmen videos
die wir sehr lieben jetzt möchten wir
gerne zum ersten mal so einen großen
trip zusammen machen und wir würden uns
wahnsinnig freuen wenn ihr uns dabei
unterstützt mit einer unterstützung
möchten wir das projekt easy german
ausbauen
wir haben den usa die größte zielgruppe
außerhalb deutschlands und möchten euch
gerne besuchen zu hause im schulklassen
oder wo auch immer ihr seid und neue
zuschauer den usa gewinnen als
unterstützer unserer kampagne werdet ihr
exklusiv bei unserem trip dabei sein und
zwar werdet ihr nicht nur die videos
sehen die wir bei youtube osten sondern
ihr werdet auch teil seiner whatsapp
gruppe wo wir täglich fotos und videos
einstellen und natürlich auch mit euch
auf deutsch beherrscht uns dabei endlich
mal wieder gemeinsam vor der kamera zu
stehen
ihr wisst haben schon ein paar videos
gedreht man an weihnachten oder in
berlin aber wir wurden in
unterschiedlichen städten in deutschland
und so können wir einen schritt machen
und
endlich zusammen videos kennen und jetzt
kommt das beste als unterstützer unserer
kampagne bekommt die exklusiven zugang
zu unserem ersten german bowl daran
haben wenn du dich schon dieses jahr
gearbeitet und wir wollen dass im herbst
veröffentlichen und wenn ihr uns mit
einer kleinen spende unterstützt bekommt
ihr dieses buch als erstes darin findet
ihr vokabeln und viele übungen zu den
verschiedenen easy german episoden soll
jetzt amerikanisch auch vor die kamera
bekommen freust du dich schon auf die
reise in die usa
ja ich freue mich total auf die da ist
das schon mal dort ich war noch nie dort
seit wie vielen jahren würdest du gerne
in die usa ein
seit meiner kindheit amerika war immer
für uns jungen leuten wollen ein ziel
nein leider noch nicht aber jetzt bin
und mein freund du dich auch ja absolut
ich bin übersetzte bei risiken und ich
das heißt ich bin immer nicht zu hause
bei der arbeit und das wirklich cool
dann jetzt eigentlich mit und freust du
dich schon weißt du schon mal da
angeschoben mit zehn war ich da aber ich
gehöre
mich nicht so gut und ja wir freuen uns
wenn ihr uns unterstützt wir konnten in
die kampagne komme werde dort viele
verschiedene parks finden viele frische
sachen die ihr bekommt und dann hier im
link bei youtube findet ihr den link zur
kampagne und wenn ihr schon in der
kampagne seit guckt unbedingt was ihr
dort bekommt werden viele schöne sachen
für euch die ihr bekommen wenn ihr uns
unterstützt wir freuen uns auf euch und
bedanken uns vergessen nicht auch uns
einzuladen und zu schreiben wo wir
hinfahren sollen und wo wir euch treffen
können danke fürs zuschauen bis bahr
hält
und jetzt unsere lieblings songs mit
amerika kids in america
francisco habe ich heute unter der
dusche gehört vor lauter vorfreude